los pandora paper es una de las mayores
filtraciones de documentos financieros
implican al menos a 14 líderes de
américa latina 3 de ellos dirigentes
activos en la región sebastián piñera en
chile guillermo la su en ecuador y luís
habían der en la república dominicana
acusados de estrategias para ocultar su
dinero en paraísos fiscales y así evitar
pagar impuestos los activos financieros
de mi familia se encuentran
administrados en fideicomisos ciegos lo
que por mandato de la ley significa que
yo no conozco las inversiones que
realizan las instituciones financieras
profesionales todas ellas reguladas por
la autoridad desde ecuador el presidente
lazo también negó haber operado con
hasta 14 sociedades inscritas en
paraísos fiscales como indica la
publicación
cumplo con lo expuesto en la ley todos
mis ingresos han sido declarados y he
pagado los impuestos correspondientes en
ecuador' siempre con transparencia y
frontalidad ante el pueblo ecuatoriano
además los papeles mencionan al menos a
tres mil mexicanos como el actual
secretario de transporte que según el
presidente lópez obrador deben rendir
responsabilidades entonces que se aclare
también el origen del dinero
porque
este hay
empresarios
[Música]
ay
políticos
legisladores
de méxico y de todo el mundo tener
sociedades opción no es necesariamente
ilegal pero si el desvío de fondos y la
evasión de impuestos algo que intenta
esclarecer la investigación